[Music]
mary's calling in from st
louis got some some political conflicts
and stress
in the family mary tell us about it
hi dr dean ken i'm so grateful for you
guys
um dr d you've been giving us tons of
great advice about
how to handle conflict stemming from
political tensions
it's been so helpful i'm not i'm not
super great with it as you can see
right so i'm john and i fight about
politics every day in the office that's
what he's
telling you that's right well it's been
better than nothing
well i appreciate you're a kind kind
person thank you
thanks um so yesterday dave made a funny
comment about the advice being great
assuming the other person that you're
dealing with wasn't mentally ill
but what if that person does have a
history of mental illness and emotional
problems
and boundary issues can you please throw
out some healthy ways
and exit strategies to end politically
divisive interrogation
and yes for me it has been interrogation
and could you please share some handy
phrases that could excuse yourself from
even going there
i want to live out proverbs 15 1 which
says
a gentle answer turns away wrath but a
harsh word stirs up anger
i mean that's such a great question
there's a couple of things
uh globally here one is um
yeah i actually um talked to somebody
today
dave and i yesterday were the the call
mary's referring to is
um dave and i yesterday talked about an
instagram post i don't watch the news
kid you know this y'all give me a hard
time back there
that um i'm more interested in local
stuff and what's in people's hearts and
minds and not on tv and
um i posted something with the word
unity in it
and you would have thought man i was the
second co
it was wild stuff i learned all about
myself i learned more about myself from
the
the internet's comments yes and dave and
i were talking about on the air um
he said man i didn't know you were a
liberal i found out i had to find it on
instagram and i said damn i told you i
was a liberal in my
in interview and we were laughing
carrying on being silly
and we got to laughing about
man if somebody if people have mental
illness they're not going to hear you
and you know what i should have been
laughing about that because there's
folks like mary there's folks like me
there's folks like
millions of people who've got people
with that actually struggle with
mental health issues it's not something
to make fun of dave and i we're having a
good time but i think you're right mary
and i think you treat this the same as
you treat any hard conversation
with somebody um who believes something
different than you
which is compassion and you just decide
to not go to war if somebody wants to
interrogate you
you do have permission whether they have
mental health issues
whether they have any sort of of
challenges with communication
you have a right to be safe and you have
a right to your boundaries
and i often will tell folks mental
health responses mental health
challenges
are context not an excuse yeah just
because somebody has a mental health
issue does not give them permission to
treat you poorly to interrogate you to
beat you up to be ugly to you or
anything like that
and so when somebody does and i've got
this in my family
when somebody comes at you with can you
believe i will stop and say hey
we're not talking politics here not
going to do that today i'm not going to
have this conversation
i do though i want to hear about how
little susie's doing i wanna hear how
your job is going
um or let's just hug we're not gonna do
it and i'm silly about it at my house
cause i'll say hey we're just gonna hug
it out
but i i don't engage with conversations
with people who are not interested in
listening to me yeah
all right and that's a it's the way i
navigate it that's why i like talking
with you ken because
you hear different conversations i hear
different conversations
and the thing i like about you ken is
that nobody knows where we're ever gonna
land on anything
and that makes my heart feel good yeah
how do you approach that conversation
well i think very similar to what you're
saying i think that you know she's
she's thinking how do i say it in a very
kind gentle way you know instead of the
hard you know heisman trophy stance you
know stop we're not doing that because
that can also
put you in a tough situation and i think
it's a i think it's a preemptive strike
i think in her situation it's a sit down
and go hey i love you deeply
and i know you like to talk about this
stuff but i actually don't like to talk
about not because
not because i disagree with you or i
think that you're wrong it just makes me
uncomfortable
and i would just prefer that we don't do
it so i just want you to know ahead of
time
it's not anything that you've done it's
not you it's me i'm just that
comfortable i'm doing this in other
areas of my life
and it just it just it's just nobody's
ever going to see eye to eye
and and neither one of us are going to
solve actually any major national
problems or local actual policy problems
by fighting amongst ourselves and so
i just think for our relationship and
this is me my standard not yours
i don't want you to feel bad about
target you can talk about it around me
and i'm not going to interject and i'm
not going to debate you but if you don't
mind i just want to create a
a thing where we're just going to talk
about it and i think i'd be preemptive
there
so that we put a boundary up before it
happens in the moment
for thanksgiving and for christmas um
we had people come for christmas and i
actually sent an email out and said
here's the topics we are not going to
discuss
yeah that's a pre-emptive started out
there right i like that and we had a
great time yeah and a couple of times it
started to kind of eek into there
there was some hands put up yeah like
we're doing that yeah because i love you
and if we can't be civil about it i'm
not well you're not whatever the
consequence let's just don't do it yeah
and and i think you know
i don't think i've ever talked about
this on the show so this is this is kind
of fun
and i think what i want the audience to
know
is that i used to be in politics
full-time what
you knew this no i didn't know this no
yeah i worked uh
i worked on a congressional race at the
age of 19. oh my life just got so much
1994
and then i was working for the governor
of virginia at the age of 22. okay
so i was a special assistant to governor
jim gilmore and so i
there was a season in my life where i
thought i was called
to politics i had a
career in calling crisis in my early 30s
because i lost the taste for it
gotcha i was irritated with both sides
of the aisle so don't anybody doing a
bunch of guesswork and send me emails
which by the way i don't read any emails
that are negative so
if i say something right now that
somehow offends you you can email i'm
never going to read it so
spare yourself i will send it to me you
you enjoy that kind of stuff yeah
but here's what i found out i lost the
fire in the belly i lost the passion for
the work
and the results of the mission that
career crisis is now what informs all
the work that i do right so you didn't
know any of that but here's my point
having worked in politics and being a
guy who though i no longer work in it
and i don't want to work in it and by
the way i don't want to return to it
either so
let's go ahead and make that
announcement i have learned of
a really clear lesson that i think would
help us all when it comes to
political talk and co-workers and family
and friends
i have never one time john in a debate
with a family member
a friend or a co-worker i have never one
time changed their mind
you did you didn't you didn't uh no
argue someone into submission no
never once that did the end of a
political debate even if it was
not nasty and i don't really have nasty
ones but never one time have i
had a political discussion with somebody
who's on the opposite end of the
spectrum or
completely on the other side of an issue
and not one time they went ken
well i tell you what i made my points
and i really really believe my points
but after you made your points i got to
tell you i
see it exactly the way you see it thank
you
ken for enlightening me and setting me
on
the right path has that ever happened
for you zero times
so therefore i've never
i've never twitter response or facebook
responded
somebody to change somebody's mind yeah
but i will tell you this
at my house i have had people spend the
night at my house
that would have made bernie sanders go
whoa that's pretty far over there yeah
and i've had people spend the night at
my house that trump would have been like
ah it's probably a little bit too far to
the right for me let's all bring it back
a little bit yeah
everyone's welcome at my table yeah and
we're gonna serve food together and
we're going to talk and we're going to
figure some of this out
somebody an astute listener one of the
dave ramsey show one time wrote in
and said i get the sense that you and
dave
think differently on some things and we
talked about it and i said
yep we have very
very matching boundaries i mean values
we want to help people we love people we
care about our faith we care about our
families
we have different beliefs and that's
beautiful because our values are
together
and dave wants to help somebody and
sometimes he wants to help him by
letting him have it and i want to i want
to help him by hugging them out
our beliefs are going to change and if i
do the hard work of reading and learning
and listening my beliefs are going to
change all over my lifetime and i hope
they do
but my value's gonna be rude and
anchored in and i think if we did this
value belief work across the country
you'd see a connection happen from the
floor up man let me remind everybody
something i say on the ken coleman show
all the time the one thing that
every human being on the planet can
unify around then there might be more
than one thing
but one thing for sure oh i'm gonna use
it you know we can be
unified around that we all want to make
a difference in this world we want to
make a difference
let's be about that this is the dave
ramsey show